Build it.
Draw it.
Play it.
Vsauce!
This is your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people.
This is BiDiPi.
Build it
Colin Furze built his own jet engine and puts
it on...everything.
He made a jet powered snow blower, a jet powered
bicycle, drove a mobility scooter 70mph in
the snow and also made a video about building
a jet engine with a drill, grinder, and toilet
brush holder.
His most recent video is the cake-o-matic
in which eight spoons, one cake, and a lot
of power feeds him birthday cake.
Sort of.
Check out his YouTube channel for more.
Victor Sonna creates these twisted bike sculptures
that he feels represent life's ride.
He uses old parts to create them and says
that society is not defined by what we create
but by what we refuse to destroy.
Some models include the Guernica, The Persistence
of Memory, and Boogie Woogie.
Mandy Smith uses sandpaper to transform everyday
objects into uncomfortable creations.
All of these objects take on a much different
feeling once made out of sandpaper such as
a slide, a bed and toilet paper.
Draw it.
Andreas Englund created this aging superhero
series where he chronicles the life and times
of a superhero.
From his young days getting caught by the
paparazzi and having a hangover, to having
a baby and becoming an old man.
"I Fought The Law" is a photo series by Olivia
Locher dramatizing strange state laws.
For instance in Alabama it's illegal to have
an ice cream cone in your back pocket.
Others include laws from Hawaii, Connecticut,
Delaware, Texas, Wisconsin, and California.
And now for "The Last Supper" by Platonova
Nataliya.
Illustrations of different versions of the
last supper creatively placed on notebooks.
Mark Wagner created this intricate art series
using one dollar bills that plays with the
concept that money is just another material.
The pieces themselves are all closely related
to currency such as wealth and the division
of wealth and capitalism.
Play it.
Caleb does death metal clarinet covers - here's
his version of Spheres of Madness by Decapitated.
Andrew Huang performs an entire rap song without
ever using the letter E.
MetroGnome created this amazing electronic
remix of the Breaking Bad theme.
Finally, "Life is Music" by Sour features
a spinning CD as a Phenakistoscope using 189
spinning CD's.
Submit your BiDiPis as a personal message
here on YouTube.
Or share them with everyone over at Facebook.com/VsauceTWO.
Click here for a brand new installment of
BiDiPi Radio.
Music created and submitted by you guys.
Also check out Your BiDiPi - an entire video
dedicated to just your creations.
And as always - thanks for watching.